dear fellow scholars this is two minute
papers with károly shown IFA here today
we are going to talk about an algorithm
that is capable of filling holes in
space and time classical image in
painting or in other words filling holes
in images is something that we've
explored in earlier episodes there are
several incredible techniques to take
care of that but with this piece of work
it is possible to generalize such a
technique for video and fill holes for
not only one image but a series of
images like removing an umbrella to
create an unaccredited to the beach or
removing a waving person from a video of
us jogging these results are truly
incredible and even though this method
was published long long ago it still
enjoys a great deal of reverence among
computer graphics practitioners not only
that but this algorithm also serves the
basis of the awesome content aware fill
feature in Adobe Photoshop cs5 in this
problem formulation we have to make sure
that our solution has spatio-temporal
consistency what does this mean exactly
this means that holes can exist through
space and time so multiple frames of a
video may be missing or there may be
regions that we wish to cut out not only
for one image but for the entirety of
the video the field in regions have to
be consistent with their surroundings if
they are looked at as an image but there
also has to be a consistency across the
time domain otherwise we would see a
disturbing flickering effect in the
results it is a really challenging
problem indeed because there are more
constraints that we have to adhere to
however a key observation is that it is
also easier because in return we have
access to more information that comes
from the previous and next frames in the
video for instance here you can see an
example of retouching old footage by
removing a huge pesky artifact and
clearly we know the fact that Charlie
Chaplin is supposed to be in the middle
of the image only because we have this
information from the previous and next
frames all this is achieved by an
optimization algorithm that takes into
consideration that consistency has to be
enforced through the spatial and the
time
domaine at the same time it can also be
used to fill in completely missing
frames of a video or it also helps where
we have parts of an image missing after
being removed by an image stabilizer
algorithm video editors do this all the
time
so such a restoration technique is super
useful the source code of this technique
is available I've put a link to it in
the video description thanks for
watching and for your generous support
and I'll see you next time
[Music]
you